[Music]
hey guys and welcome to game sports
weekly game of thrones show I'm Lucy
you're three-eyed crow here to guide you
through the comings goings the headings
and of course sexings of Westeros we've
still got a couple of weeks before
season six kicks off on April 24th so
what better time to recap the seven most
sensational moments from season five
fair warning we're going to be spoiling
the hell out of season five but don't
worry there isn't going to be a sand
snake in sight because they were the
worst bit season five wasn't kind to
Cersei the Queen Regent had to suffer
one indignity after the other her father
just died her youngest and only
remaining son now favors his new wife
over her and her daughter is being held
captive by those people we don't talk
about in dawn so sir she does what she
always does and pull the terrible power
play that totally backfires in at number
seven Circe's walk of shame reinstating
the faith militant which is a religious
military order must have seemed like a
good idea at the time and I did actually
work out in Circe's favor at least at
the beginning her betrothed to Loras
gets arrested for his homosexual affairs
and his sister mantri gets arrested and
thrown in jail too because she lied
under oath to protect him which is great
for Cersei until you remember that her
cousin and part-time lover lancel is now
a member of the faith he snitches on her
to the high Sparrow who then orders
Circe's arrest she gets thrown in jail
for amongst other things incest treason
and regicide not looking good for Cersei
after being humiliated and kept in a
jail cell she then admits to her crimes
and she stripped naked her beautiful
long blond hair is shaven and she's made
to walk through the streets of King's
Landing while all of the residents yell
obscenities at her
[Music]
[Applause]
it is a really powerful scene that you
know is just gonna fuel Circe's motives
for season six she's always been
power-hungry but now she wants revenge
and oh who's this guy the end he just
picks her up could it be well i'm not
saying Clegane ball has been confirmed
but things start to get boring for
dinero's pretty much as soon as she sets
up camp in murine a lot of Khaleesi
admin to get through mostly to do with
the bloody fighting pits and the fact
that her lover Daario naharis changes
his face completely and no one ever
mentions it anyway things finally get
legitimately interesting for Daenerys
when our favorite Empyrean manages to
escape from King's Landing having killed
his father and make his way across the
Narrow Sea in a box in at number 6 it's
Tyrion becoming denair as's advisor
here's where the game of thrones pot
gets even thicker dinero's has the claim
to the Iron Throne and she's got the
Dragons in which to take it but she
needs Tyrians insight and his smarts in
order to do it a bonus hang on to this
moment is that surge or a moment gets
grayscale and so hopefully that's the
end of him in at number five a moment
that was shocking controversial and
completely unexpected Ramsey raping
Sansa Stark while reek helplessly looks
on this moment in particular scared book
readers because this fate isn't supposed
to be sensors at all in the books at her
old best friend gene pool who's
masquerading is alia who gets married
off to the brute we have to watch the
young stark girl suffer at Ramsay's
hands it keeps forcing himself on her
she's covered in bruises and not only
that his lover and bed-warmer Miranda
keeps dropping these dark hints and
threats as to what happens to the girls
who don't please Ramsay they're used in
hunting and attacked and killed by packs
of dogs mother's light at the end of the
tunnel for the young Stark together with
reek they managed to escape and jump
from Winterfell battlements into the
unknown
another generis moment in at number four
dragons return after finally giving in
and reopening the fighting pits
everything seems calm in murine so what
better time for dinero's to go down and
watch a fight everything seems to be
going well until the sons of the harpy
make their play and try and kill her
outnumbered and surely doomed luckily
drogon finally comes back from wherever
it is he's been to save his mama what
results is an epic flame ridden boss
fight where drogon basically goes ham on
all the sons of the harpy before
whisking dinero's away to safety I say
safety he does admittedly drop her in
the clutches of a khalasar who then take
a prisoner but still she's the first
dragon rider in over a century
in at number three then are you becoming
a faceless man so I spends most of
season five washing corpses in the house
of black and white waiting for Jack and
Hagar to tell her that she's finally
ready to become an assassin the faceless
man but her impatience gets the best of
her when Sir Meryn Trant rolls into
Braavos you remember Sumerian as a
member of the Kingsguard and murderer of
lovely water dancer / sword instructor
Syrio Forel turns out so Marin likes the
younger girls so i er goes into the Hall
of faces and steals the face of a quite
young girl in order to get close to him
when this works she uses the opportunity
to kill him by stabbing him through the
eye while it's one more name to cross
off her list jackin Hegar is not so
happy he says that Sumerian was taken
too soon and then only death pays for
life so what does he do mom he grabbed
some poison and drinks it and then dies
what does he arya peels off his face to
reveal that it's not him at all and then
peels off loads of faces the final face
is arias herself everything goes black
and she struck blind thus beginning her
training to become a faceless man
what's happening we're really used to
seeing adults copy on Game of Thrones
but I don't think anybody was ready for
number two the sacrifice of Shireen
Baratheon poor lovely little Shireen
after leading a life of imprisonment and
isolation as a result of her grayscale
infection it think it would be time for
something to go right for her sure any
way I can help but it seems the ride is
a game of thrones had other ideas
Stannis's army is faltering it's really
heavy snow in the north meaning the
company move anywhere and Rameses taken
Winterfell to add insult to injury armed
with only 20 men Ramsay attacks
Stannis's stronghold under the cover of
night destroying loads of food tents and
killing a bunch of horses old ser Davos
is sent back up to Castle black in order
to try and drum up some wildling support
while he's gone Melisandre suggests
sacrificing some more Kings blood to the
Lord of Light to try and turn things in
their favor sadly the only Kings blood
around belongs to Shireen and the poor
little girl is burnt at the stake while
the blood magic kind of works because
the snow melts the army pretty much ups
and desserts because they're so repulsed
by what they've seen her mother ends up
hanging herself Stannis gets stabbed by
Brienne of Tarth and Melisandre fleas so
yeah this one definitely didn't pan out
what else could be at number one but the
betrayal of Jon Snow is he dead is he
alive did he walk out at the last minute
how did everyone's favorite
floppy-haired wildling lover end up
bleeding in the snow well in season five
jon is chosen by his brothers to become
the new Commander of the Nights Watch
but upon his election he starts making
some really unpopular decisions like for
hedging the insolent but popular
channels lint he also promises to save a
bunch of wildlings by offering them safe
passage and land to settle in south of
the wall he also loses his biggest
allies Maester Aemon dies of old age and
sam takes Gilly and baby Sam to old town
in order to train to become a
replacement maester so when John steward
Ali comes to him and says there's been
reported sightings of his uncle Benjen
things might be looking up for young
snow it turns out sightings of Uncle
Benjen also look a lot like mutiny and
the young snow is stabbed to death by a
bunch of his brothers who keep muttering
for the watch the final jab is of course
provided by Ali the little [ __ ]
[Music]
so those are my biggest seven moments
from Game of Thrones Season five we've
got two short weeks until season six
starts so join me next week I'll be
putting on my tin foil hat and going
over my favorite fan theories and
predictions for the upcoming series in
the meantime if you've got any favorite
predictions or Game of Thrones moments
be sure to check them in the comments
box below or come find me on Twitter I'm
at Lucy James games I'll see you next
time
[Music]